[موسيقى]
ام
لكن بن الانباري خمسه اقوال اهل اللغه في
معنى اسم المسيح ابن مريم عليهما السلام
احدها انه قيل له مسيح ل سياحته في الارض
تجوال لدعوه وذكر ايضا انه وصف بالمسيح
لانه كان ممسوح الرجل دون اخلص يمس الارض
من باطن الرجل و سمي مسيحا لانه خرج من
بطن امه ممسوحا بالدهن
ولقب ايضا بالمسيح الصديق فيما اشهر
المعاني انه سمي مسيحا لانه كان لا يمس حد
عاهه الا برئ وكان يحيي الموتى باذن الله
اما المسيح الدجال الذي يعد ظهوره من
علامات الساعه الكبرى عند المسلمين يقولون
ان ما قيل له مسيح لانه ممسوح العين
الواحده يسعى في الخراب والضلال ولا يصدقه
الا الجهات الى العناوين
السياسي يمسح على مريضه مقعده ف ترى النور
نانسي عجرا تدخل على خط تعديل الدستور
ايه صالح والانذار الاخير قبل توقيف توفيق
الم ثم ان يكتشف قتيلا يقاتل في طرابلس
والاماراتيون اكتشفوا التسلق قبل الامارات
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بعد وصفه من مرجع ازهري بانه رسول
من عند الله وبعد رؤيه كان مصري بان الله
اختاره لانقاذ مصر من الموت وبعد ادعاء
صحيفه مصريه ان سيد الخلق زاره في المنام
بعد ان خرج من بطن امه ساجدا متبسما
للحاضرين كان التسلسل المنطقي هذه
الروايات يعد باعلانه قديسا وليا او اكثر
وقد تاخرت مراسيم التطوير عبد الفتاح
السيسي مسح على مصابه بالسرطان قابلته وهي
على كرسي متحرك
فتحركت عندما رات النور ومشت ومشت وما
تزال تمشي اذا مشيت عليك
[موسيقى]
يعني
يقولون اذا كان جمال عبد الناصر فان عبد
الفتاح هو المنصور واذا كان السادات محمد
انور فان سيد السادات محمد نوره في المنام
واذا كان لقب حسني مبارك فان السياسي
مبارك للمرضى والمقرضين واذا كان مارس
اشتغل في الناس فان السياسي اشتغل في
الناس وهم اليوم مدعوون للتصويت لتعديل
الدستور بعد اقراره نيابيا ليبقى الرئيس
رئيسا حتى عشرين ثلاثين كخطوه اولى مع
ابنائه الثلاثه يضحون في سبيل كم مش
عارفين انكم نور عينينا
ولكن اذا الموافقه مرتبطه بنزول المصريين
موافقه المصريين على هذه التعديلات اذن
الشعب ولا احد غير الشعب هذا الصعب الذي
يملك القرار اطلق حمله باطل لرفض الدستور
مطاردتها المخابرات وحدثت اربعه وثلاثين
الف موقع لتحول باطل الى حق
اساسي استعان بين عشره من لبنان لاجراء
عمليات تجميل و تعديل للدستور
[موسيقى]
ام
المبنى راجل
[موسيقى]
الرئيس السياسي اذا مسح على المريضه ال
مقعده في مشهد وقبلها التقى الرئيس
السوداني عمر البشير
وصافحه
وعزل من الرئاسه اكثر من ذلك في اقل من
اربع وعشرين ساعه اطيح بالبشير واستقيل
رئيس المخابرات صلاح بوش فيما استقال خلف
البشير رئيس المجلس العسكري الانتقالي عوض
بن عوف قبل ان يسكن مقعده ليش لانه تذكر
الاولياء الصالحين كيف كانوا يشاهدون في
المناصب تشعر السودان من هول التواضع ولا
اريد الا ان قيمه باذن الله
في المناصب المواقع الرفيع بعد عرض كان
العوض بالفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيسا
للمجلس العسكري الانتقالي الذي سيحكم
البلاد سنتين قبل ان تجري انتخابات رئاسيه
اعلنت قوى الاجماع الوطني تمسكها ب رفضها
القاطع من استلام القوات المسلحه للسلطه
في السودان ونوهت الى ان مهام الجيش يجب
ان تقتصر على حمايه وتامين الانتقال
السلمي للسلطه مدنيا لجماهير الشعب المحلل
السياسي السعودي خالد باطرفي غض الطرف عن
تغطيه الجزيره الاحتجاجات الشعبيه على حكم
البشير حتى ان هذا البرنامج خصص حلقه
بعنوان بوتفليقه الخامس والبشير المؤبد
فاتهمها بالتلفون يعني الان تتبرعون منه
وتعلنون ان فترته كانت فتره اه فساد وفتره
اه ظلم اين كانت هذه الاراء سواء في
الجزيره او في الحكومه القطريه او التركيه
باحث سعودي اخر ماجد التركي اسفل ما وصفه
بتنكر اعلامهم للبشير شفتش حلب الموضوعيه
الذي لم يعجبني حديد ولم يرى في اعلام
العربيه بالذات القريب منا بدا يتناول
شخصيه البشير بتناول ات سلبيه السيئه
وكاننا يعني ننسى دور البشير الحقيقه في
وقفه التحالف العربي في اليمن السودان
قدم دعم
للتحالف العربي بدون طلب وهذه كلمه حق
الريال هذا نحن ما طلبناه
لكن هذه فائزه عن حل ما نقول في الامارات
باسمكم الريد نشكر فخامه الرئيس ونقول له
اول شي بغريبه على اخواننا في السودان
ولها غريبه على ريال عائشه عندنا وكل من
خبزتنا وعيشنا وملحنا
ونقول شكرا
ونحن هذا الموقف من خلفه على عيالنا وعيال
العيان او امانه في السعوديه والامارات
اوفدت اه وفدا مشتركا مجهول الاسماء
والصفات الى الخرطوم واجتمع بالجنرال
البرهان في جن حزمه الكاميرات بعدما سارعت
الرياض وابو ظبي مع القاهره الى اعلان
تاييد المجلس العسكري الذي اطاح بالبشير
اعلنت المملكه العربيه السعوديه تاييدها
لخيار الشعب السوداني حيال مستقبلي وما
اتخذه المجلس العسكري الانتقالي من
اجراءات تصب في مصلحه الشعب السوداني كما
رحبت دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
بتسليم الفريق او الركن عبد الفتاح المراه
رئاسه المجلس العسكري الانتقالي السوداني
في خطوه تجسد تطلعات الشعب السوداني في
الامن والاستقرار والتنميه عند الوفاء
طالبت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه احدى
القنوات الفضائيه ان تنفي ما نقلته حول
رفض السودان استقبال وفد قطري برئاسه وزير
الخارجيه محمد بن عبد الرحمان الثاني
واوضحت الخارجيه السودانيه ان الترتيبات
تجري لزياره وفد قطري رفيع المستوى
للخرطوم واذا اردت صديقي المشاهد ان تعرف
اكثر عن هذه الفضائيه فاقرا هذه التغريده
على امل ان لا يكون دعم حلف قمار للسودان
ناريا كما هو الحال في اليمن وليبيا وليس
بعيدا عن السودان ودعما لسلام جنوبه
البابا فرنسيس في الفاتيكان على ركبتيه في
ممارسه استثنائيه غير مالوفه وقبل اقدام
زعماء جنوب السودان طالبا منهم نبذ الحروب
والبقاء في سلام وماذا سيطلب قاده المحور
من السودانيين في السعوديه هناك من يربط
تحسن اقتصادهم بمدى توجه الخرطوم الى
الرياض وابو ظبي هذا للحد الاقتصادي امل
الحد الجنوبي الاراده السودانيين تحسين
القصه من الداخل
من ان يتوجهوا للمملكه العربي السعوديه
فعلا من اراد نهضه اقتصاد بلاده عليه
الركوب في حافله عشرين ثلاثين السعوديين
بلشوا يركبوا سيارات صينيه فقد غادرت
ستمائه حافله صينيه مقاطعه انهوي الشرقيه
الصين لتسليمها الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وقلب الصين في اليابان احتفل الامبراطور
اكيهيتو
والامبراطور
بالذكرى الستين لزواجهما قبيل تخلي
الامبراطور نهايه الشهر الجاري عن العرش
لانه الاكبر وولي عهده الامير ناروهيتو اي
ولي عهد يتمنى الان ان يحدث معهم احدث
رابط الحلقه الجزيره ونعتبره
الاسبوع
الاسبوع كان بلا منازع وزير الخارجيه الذي
فرنسيه
[موسيقى]
فرنسا ايضا متهمه في ليبيا لدى الكثيرين
باللعب على السلام والحرب
فيما اعتقل امن الحدود في تونس مجموعتين
من المسلحين الاوروبيين قادمين من ليبيا
بينهم ثلاثه عشر فرنسيا يحملون جوازات سفر
دبلوماسي
لماذا تزج باريس بجنودها في ليبيا الا
يكفيها انتحار شرطيا كل اربعه ايام داخل
فرنسا تزايد حالات الانتحار بين صفوف رجال
الشرطه اثار قلق السلطات الفرنسيه مع
انتحار ضابط شرطه خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع
ارتفع العدد الاجمالي هذا العام الى اربعه
وعشرين شرطيا فمعدل انتحار هم اعلى بنسبه
سته وثلاثين في المائه من عامه السكان
الكل يترقب الان من سينتصر ويبقى في
طرابلس ومن س يمشي والايام وتوجيه مع
ملاحظه ان السياسي مسح ايضا على حفتر
بمسحه من دعمه فهل يمشي
متحدث حفظ العسكري احمد المسماري عم يعمل
شغله كثير حلو مثلا عرض صوره ل مقاتل قال
انه ارهابي موجود الان في طرابلس هذه صور
لمجموعات الامن البعض انطلاقات الجيش
الليبي وهي من هاجمه السفاره الامريكيه
وقتلت اه عشره الليبي الان يواجهون القوات
المسلحه في طرابلس حساب فيسبوك من بنغازي
اعلن ان هذا المقاتل تابع للصاعقه من قوات
حفظ وقتل قبل سنوات مضطر المسماري الى
تقديم الاعتذار بوست خاص مع قطر المسماري
كان اكثر تشويقا فاعلن ان مجموعه الفهد
الاسود القطريه تنفذ عمليات في بنغازي
والدليل بانك انت كل العمليات الاغتيال
التي كانت في بنغازي عن طريق مجموعه الفهد
الاسود
هلمر على المسماري مثل حبل الكذب قصير
عندما كان مقدما لبرنامج الامثال الشعبيه
في التلفزيون
الحلقه نتعرف على بعض ال الحكم الشعبيه
على سيره الامثال يقول المثل السامي
الغريب لازم يكون اديب وهذا ما لم يلتزمه
جوليان اسانج مؤسس موقع ويكيليكس
وخرق اصول اللجوء بحسب حكومه الاكوادور
التي اسقطت عنه حق لجوئه الى سفارتها في
لندن بعد سبع سنوات على هروبه اليها من
الاعتقال والتسليم للولايات المتحده بسبب
نشره الاف البرقيات الفضائح حول حربي
العراق وافغانستان
فضيحه لا يحتاج نشرها الى ويكيليكس تحصل
في موريتانيا حيث يعلن عشره من اصل احد
عشر عضوا في اللجنه المشرفه على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه تاييدهم لمرشح النظام
وزير الدفاع بحسب المرشح سيدي محمد ولد
بوبكر اللجنه المشرفه على الانتخابات التي
المفروض ان تكون مستقله هي اليوم فيها احد
عشر عضوا عشر منهم يؤيدون اه مرشح النظام
وواحد فقط لم يحدد موقفه حتى الساعه اذا
كانت المخابرات الموريتانيه تتدخل فان
الجيش الجزائري ممثلا برئيس اركانه احمد
قايد صالح يصدر الانذار الاخير لجنرال
المخابرات السابق توفيق حتى لا يتحول الى
عنوان في الصحف توقيف توفيق واضاف صالح
انه يوجه للجنرال توفيق اخر اذار وان
اجراءات القانونيه الصارمه سوف تتخذ ضده
في حاله استمراره في هذه التصرفات وفي
الجزائر ايضا تقلصت الى بعض مع استقاله
اول باء الطيب بلعيز من المجلس الدستوري
في الشارع جهته لرحيل كل باء باء بفساد
عظيم قدم اليوم الثلاثاء رئيس المجلس
الدستوري الطيب بالعيد استقالته لرئيس
الدوله عبد القادر بن صالح
الشباب الجزائري اعطى الامثوله الراقيه
للحراك والتجمعات مناسبه لتجميل الطرقات
سيده مسنه حملت المكنسه ايضا لكن ليس
لتنظيف السابعه بل لتنظيف البيئه من
الباقات
من الجزائر الى تونس الجاريه حموده
مشاركه نائب رئيس البرلمان نائب رئيس حركه
عبد الفتاح
[موسيقى]
ام
يعني جماعه حركه بغضه مضطرين يغنوا وربما
يراسه حتى ما يقولوا عنهم ارهابيين واذا
انه اتفضلوا شو بيقولوا عنه جماعه نداء
تونس
الراس والفرنسيه ما هو مش كيف كيف شفت شكل
الواحد حجاب معناها تشوف نفوق بتقول مدينا
قناه اقرا وتشوف من وطالب سجين محالهم عن
اهم تعرف انا مش من فوق اقرا ومن لو طارت
انا بنفس المنطق حزب النداء تونس اصبح
القناه الاولى والقناه الثانيه حزبين ب
رئيسيه على الرغم من ان الشعار المؤتمر
كان لم الشمل فقد انتهى بالانقسام الى
مؤتمرين لانتخاب القياده احدهما في مدينه
الحمامات وانتخب النائب في البرلمان سفيان
طوال رئيسا للجنه المركزيه للحزب والثاني
في مدينه المنستير وانتخب حافظ السيسي
رئيسا للجنه المركزيه للحزب ذاته حب
الشهره يفرق الجماعات واحيانا يفرق بين
المرء
تدعي انها المهدي
بتقول لك المهدي
يا اخواننا اقسم بالله العظيم لو انه
[موسيقى]
رئيس ما لم يتم حتى الان في اليمن عبدربه
منصور هادي يؤكد ان اولوياته هزيمه
الانقلاب انهم اولوياتنا في الوقت الراهن
يتمثل في هزيمه الانقلاب وبناء مؤسسات
الدوله وتعزيز وجود اي انقلاب الحوثي
المدعوم من ايران ام الجنوبي المدعوم من
الامارات الاستعمار البريطاني
ليس اه يعني وجود كان افضل بكثير تجلب
نحنا الان ست عندنا سعدنا ارضنا والحمد
لله تعالى وان طالب استفتاء الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس
عندما يرفض يرفض وعندما يغضب يغضب لكنه
يحتفظ بحق الغضب حدود سبعه وستين
كما
وانا
انا كمان يعني
[موسيقى]
في عمان رئيس الحكومه عمر الرزاز يفسر
الاردنيين بان نسبه الفقر في البلاد هي
15.7 بالموقف فقط ما يعني ان الاردنيين
صار وضعهم افضل من الالمان فقر المطلق
والخمسطاش فاصل سبعه من المواطنين
الاردنيين في ضمن الفقر المطلق وجاء في
نسخه العام الفين وثلاثه عشر من التقرير
الذي يصدره الاتحاد باريس شي كل سنه
بالاستناد الى بيانات من معهد الاحصاءات
الالماني تستطع ان الفقر الذي بلغت نسبته
خمسه عشر فاصل اثنين في المائه وصل للاسف
الشديد الى مستوى قياسي جديد في العام
الفين واثني عشر
خلف حريق كاتدرائيه نوتردام في باريس صدمه
في فرنسا والعالم لاسيما الكاثوليكي وقد
ادى الحريق الى سقوط برج الكاتدرائيه
المدرجه على قائمه التراث العالمي وفيما
قال المدعي العام الفرنسي انه لا توجد
اشارات الى ان الحقيقه متعمد علق احدهم
انه بذلك تكون الامه الاسلاميه قد نجت
باعجوبه من تهمه ال احراق الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب
ونصح فرنسا باطفاء الحريق عبر الطوافات
يثير موجه سخريه حيث علق الدفاع المدني
الفرنسي بالقول
نصائح كفيله بهدم الكاتدرائيه بكاملها
طبيب امريكي مسلم قتلت ابنته المحجبات ان
بجريمه طائفيه على
قبل اربع سنوات
امام اعضاء الكونغرس في جلسه استماع
ماذا تتوقعون
الاسرائيلي باجراء تعديلات على القران
واستشهد
[موسيقى]
استاذ في جامعه الازهر يطلب من طلابه خلع
ملابسهم بالكامل مقابل اعطائهم درجه
امتياز وقد وافق احد الطلاب وخلع ورقه
التوت التي اسقطت معها الاستاذ ورئيس
القسم والوكيل والعميد من الوظيفه وعندما
سئل المدرس عن تصرفه قال انه درس في
الحياه
علينا البنطلون في
[موسيقى]
الفارين من
بين السائل والمجيب مع شيخ الترميم عادل
الكلباني تتحول الوسطيه الى هز الوسط
والاعتدال الى تصفيق الرجال في الحفلات
الطوال ايهما افضل يقول يوما والتصفيق من
الرقص عند حضور حفلات
اخونا اسمه فلان الفلاني كل والله يا اخي
شوف ماذا تذكر انت لان الرجل او المر
مطالب بان يفعل ما يكون في الرقص
واذا اتقنت التصديق تصفق واذا اقرت الغني
ايضا
للامانه شاهدته الفيديو مرتين وسعته بان
عادل الشيخ الخاص يسخر من سؤال المتصل بل
يسخر من واقع الحال برمته بترميز يحتاج فك
الشيفره هكذا تشعر
اخيرا يتسلق التسلق الى قائمه الاكتشافات
الاماراتيه صدق او لا تصدق تسلق الجبال
اكتشفه اهل راس الخيمه قبل اكتشاف دوله
الامارات
هذه
الجبال او ما يسمونها
[موسيقى]
ختاما كان محاسب محطه وقود سوداني يقفوا
يملا خزان سياره نقل بضائع صغيره بالبنزين
ولما فرغ واقفل الخزان غادر صاحب السياره
وقرر ان لا يدفع المال فاق لعبها بلمح
البصر لتسبق بديئه المحاسب السوداني سرعه
الصوت ف يقفز الى صندوق السياره المكشوف
ليقبض على السارق في اللحظه المناسبه
ينصح كثيرون لا تجرح سودانيا فهو يجمع دون
كرامته و لا تقحم ان فك في امرهم وامرهم
شورى بينهم ولا تظلم اهل السودان فانهم
قضاه العرب ان لم يكن اليوم بعد حين الى
اللقاء
ام
[موسيقى]